check this out this chart shows the
stock price of a basket of airlines
after two years of seeing air travel
decimated by kovig 19 many airlines were
hoping for a strong recovery in 2022 but
now that recovery is in question
the war in ukraine has led to bans on
imports exports closed airspace soaring
oil prices and sanctions we're banning
all imports of russian oil and gas it's
forcing some airlines to once again
rethink how they operate while the
industry turmoil isn't on the scale of
the humanitarian crisis many ukrainians
are facing the conflict does mean that
instead of recovering some airlines are
facing yet more uncertainty and so i do
think we'll see more failures this year
than we've seen during the whole of the
pandemic so what challenges are airlines
navigating to stay airborne and which
companies are most exposed let's find
out
okay firstly i want to explore closed
airspace a band over russian carrier
aeroflot entering uk airspace sparked a
tit-for-tat of flight bans that resulted
in western airlines being unable to fly
over russia and russian airlines being
unable to fly over much of the west this
is creating a headache for some us
routes that would normally fly over the
arctic and down through russia for
example united has temporarily suspended
its routes between newark and mumbai and
linking san francisco and new delhi but
few airlines face a bigger route
headache than finnish carrier thin air
which marketed itself as a transfer
point for travellers between asia and
europe the company's marketing used to
include the phrase fly the shortcut that
shortcut was over russia and for them
it's now very much closed they're
looking at their route to bangkok
from helsinki now takes three hours
longer in a statement the company said
they wouldn't be able to fly to all of
their asian destinations even if western
airlines find a way to operate a full
service by flying around russia they
still risk losing business to
competitors who can fly straight over
russian airspace so if you look at
lufthansa going to beijing now they have
to compete against air china who can go
straight across russia and their flight
will take an hour and a half less
next is fuel costs which have been on a
wild ride by march 8 the price of crude
had climbed some 64 higher than the
start of 2022 around the same time the
price of jet fuel was almost double what
it was a year ago airlines have to
somehow recoup the extra cost typically
fuel is about 20 of their costs are
pretty significant but what you're going
to see and there's an alternative is
airlines actually reducing capacity to
force passengers up the yield curve so
they can't take those passengers at the
rock bottom prices anymore now some
airlines especially european ones tend
to hedge their fuel costs which is
essentially where they agree to buy a
certain quantity of fuel for a certain
price at a certain point in the future
in a bid to reduce volatility but for
airlines that are not hedged this is an
immediate hit to their cash flow uh most
of the u.s airlines in the us are
actually not hedged in america there's
only a few major airlines and domestic
demand is recovering strongly so
analysts tell me airlines should be able
to raise ticket prices and still fill a
plane but in europe it's a different
story there the airline market is less
concentrated and consumers have a wider
range of choice what's more analysts
told me that so far demand in europe
hasn't recovered as strongly as it has
in the u.s partly due to a patchwork of
covert regulations putting off
travellers what this means is that if
carriers that were unhedged when fuel
prices shot up like hungary's wizair
tried to raise ticket prices to
recapture some of those rising fuel
costs analysts told me they may struggle
to fill a plane in a statement wizair
said the company had since capped its
fuel cost exposure for the next four
months
so let's go back to this chart
does it mean that airlines are in for
yet another turbulent year well
according to one analyst for those that
aren't exposed to the crisis in ukraine
things might be okay yes i'm so
confident the industry will recover in
2022 because we've come off such a low
base some carriers earnings gonna be
fairly good this year despite what's
going on but those that are exposed now
face a difficult period on the back of a
difficult two years there are certain
routes and maybe airlines with weaker
balance sheets weaker business models
that now will fail it's because while
governments came to the rescue of many
airlines throughout the corona virus
pandemic analysts tell me that high fuel
prices or closed airspace is unlikely to
trigger a similar government aid
response that means that for some
airlines after two years of enduring the
pandemic even the slightest detour on
the route to recovery might be the final
straw
hi there this channel focuses on
transport and mobility so if you're
interested in that feel free to
subscribe however if you want to know
more about the conflict in ukraine then
my colleagues have been doing a great
job of covering the latest from that
region i've left the link below please
go check it out
[Music]
you